bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous ce
matin en direct sur arte france à paris
qui menace désormais de passer à
l'action face à une classe politique
libanaise dans l'inaction d'abord
comment est-ce qu'on réagit aujourd'hui
à beyrouth
bonjour en premier nous sommes larusso
hilliard il à l'explosion du 4 ou iard
idées des gens qui ont perdu leur vie
tout une capitale qui a qui a perdu la
vie et un gouvernement qui a présenté sa
démission une crise économique sans
merci les problèmes de tous bords la
corruption qui est toujours là les gens
ne peuvent pas le retirer leur argent
des banques
suite à à à tout ce qui s'est passé sur
le plan de l'endettement entre la banque
centrale et l'état les banques
commerciales
nous sommes là nous sommes dans un état
de désarroi politique et économie et
même vitale alors on attend que la
communauté internationale
une certaines interférences mais cette
fois ci pas par des concertations
pacifique juste avec les compositions
les composantes politiques qui ont
engendré tôt ces problèmes et qui ont
mené le pays à ce désarroi politique
c'est pour cela la pente
l'union européenne et où le mot sont en
état d' alerte il ils doivent agir
on se la classe politique qui a volé son
peuple au liban alors justement alors
faire justement puisque vous parlez
d'interférences et on en a vu les propos
de jean yves le drian comment la france
peut-elle intervenir concrètement est-ce
qu'elle en a d'abord les moyens la
france peut-être n'a pas les moyens
c'est concret c'est-à-dire politique
suite à a
il ya des axes au liban ça c'est pas un
secret il ya des axes régionaux il y en
a d'autres internationaux c'est pas la
france qui qui peut mener le jeu
mais la france ne peut pas débloquer la
situation politique et gouvernemental si
elle ne fait pas un acte juridique
claire n'est qu'en 6 et précis contre la
classe politique qui a volé son peuple
et qui a mis son argent en france dans
les pays européens en suisse dans le
camp madrilène dans le bir ivy et dans
d'autres pays
paradis fiscaux ou haute il doit bloquer
l'argent qui a été volé du peuple
libanais de l'état ont des libanais en
même temps sinon y'a pas de sanction
claire dans sept ans le positionnement
français européen et international
restait qu'à du sang résultats
quelconques le gouvernement ne peut pas
être formés et si le gouvernement le
nouveau gouvernement à voir le jour
c'est rentrer la même classe politique
il peut pas faire et un redressement au
liban ils n'ont pas les capacités ils
peuvent tout faire
vous pensez que l'action que peut
envisager la france au liban pour
débloquer la situation
huit mois après la démission du premier
ministre hassan diab est ce que vous
pensez que ça peut aller dans le sens
que vous avez à l'instant énuméré c'est
à dire justement bloquer les actifs ou
deux libanais nos personnalités
libanaises ils peuvent pas les français
les européens même même tout au tout les
grandes puissances ne peuvent pas
toujours menacé il ya des actions jeudi
d'ordre juridique et je parle en tant
que que doctorants de l'international
ils peuvent faire des actes d'ordre
juridique pour bloquer les actifs à
l'étranger et voir les sources de ces
actifs les sources
si les soupçons légitimes n'y a pas de
problème sinon le rideau il ya tout un
peuple qui a été volé il ya tout un pays
qui en l'état de dislocation même les
services fondamentaux et vitaux sont en
pénurie
c'est pour cela ils doivent agir pas par
des concertations comme sa lente et
pacifique
c'est une classe politique qui ne peut
pas connaître le redressement
il ya neuf ans 0 rodez le fonds doit
être fait immédiatement pour le sauver
ce qu'on peut sauver
alors justement c'est emmanuel macron il
est venu plusieurs fois au liban il a
reçu un accueil plutôt chaleureux de la
part des libanais dans un contexte
compliqué dans pour votre pays
qu'attendent aujourd'hui les libanais
concrètement de la france notamment en
effet on remercie le plaisir emprunt
c'est d'avoir fait deux visites dans des
situations un peu un peu de rester vous
savez il y avait le colonna qui était un
peu partout et il y avait vraiment un
état un état d'urgence au liban étape de
par le mot on le remercie toutes les
forces étrangères européennes et non
européennes qui ont une affinité avec
les liban pour le liban pour les
libanais pour cette histoire riche pour
ce pays message
jusqu'ici on n'a rien vu de concret nous
sommes dans une situation politique très
compliqué dans une situation économique
très dangereuse est dans une situation
sociale qui est vraiment voir ou revoir
devant nous la ddt problèmes des
problèmes vitaux intrinsèque qui peuvent
mener à une certaine famille entre
guillemets mais le problème peut-être
façon clair net et précis
si le coup merci merci beaucoup à vous
antoine sfeir pour cet éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes avocat maître de
conférences à l'université saint joseph
à beyrouth